yellow welcome to new video this is on
the third video in the iPhone 5
repertoire series for black and this
video will deal with them with them yeah
two openings or two lines may mostly
that white can play and that often are
transpose into each other so it's
handled in one video this is the vienna
game so on the second move on
oops 93 um and also the the bishops
opening Bishop c4 as I mentioned this
elfin transpose into to one another so
let's begin with them the bishops
opening Bishop c4 as some this has very
little yeah value on its own so to say
as it usually transpose into something
else I'm usually the Vienna but also
easily transpose into the Italian okay
Bishop c4 the MU fire suggests here's
Knight to f6 immediately attacking
attacking the e4 pawn and now white um
has two options really two to cover this
pawn and this is some Knight to c3 and
d3 of course on mostly played here is by
far d3 to cover the pawn and what's also
possible here is of course Knight c3
which transposes to the vienna directly
usually why it starts Knight c3 Knight
f6 Bishop c4 so we got the same position
this will be handled term in the Vienna
so somewhat later in the video
on d3 my suggested move is Bishop c5 and
after that usually white goes 93 and we
again transpose into the Vienna starting
with 93 on the second booth white of
course also has got Knight f3 here
attacking a5 and this can be most simply
met by 96 and we transpose into the
Italian game this sum will be handled in
a separate video later usually of course
this is reached by on the second move
Knight f3 knight c6 and then Bishop c4
so this is full of transpositions would
wide also can do he can ignore the
threat on the e4 pawn and play moves
like d4 here or 93 and these um can be
can be handled in various ways by a
transposing to something or to play some
standalone line here for instance black
could go knight c6 transposing into the
two knights they tell you but this is
not part of our main proposed repertoire
but you can also just just take this
pawn and see what white is up to usually
um he answers Knight c3 here and tries
to play in in gambit style you have
various options here to to handle this
the main known line here is sort of
funny
maybe it's um it's good for black but I
never bothered to really check this main
light here is taking and then protecting
that the e5 pawn with a somewhat ugly
looking move f6 um according to theory
this is very good for black but they're
never bothered to check it
to be honest and I usually just handle
these kind of lines by by taking here
and then continue developing with Bishop
d7 for instance and I never had any
particular problems here um so just
returning e5 so you can very often
handle these kind of gambit approaches
by by common-sense play also you can if
everything else fails you can also
simply drop this Knight back here and
you've got no problems just continue
with development you cannot get into any
crazy attacks here on f7 and if he
captures you can just win a temple here
and then continue with your development
so very often if y it goes with some
gambit approach you can um just um yeah
be not too greedy and think about your
development
don't take every every pawn that is
offered to you another option here is
plate deform as a gambit on this black
and answer with taking and now white
continues with Knight f3 oops
93 it is not good here to to play e5
because black has the typical response
d5 this is something or a motive you
really need to get used to here in the
open games if you get some sort of
position where this Bishop is on c4 and
white advances it is in more than 90
percent I guess of the cases d5 is the
right answer it is well in this position
black doesn't have any alternative move
really you cannot really consider to
going back to g8 here but also in other
positions do
five is usually the correct answer
winning this tempo on the bishop um here
wide doesn't have anything else than
give the check here stuff like this
here's just just brilliant for Blacky he
has a complete central control and even
an extra pawn so it's a complete
complete joke actually four wide so it
needs to to check here and then you can
simply play this move gained another
temple and then what needs to go for
somewhat weird look in position with
taking here or move the bishop again and
after which you can simply move the
Knight to e4 if you like so it's not not
too dangerous now they're three though
is some something you need to consider
here it is very risky to take the pawn
this gives white whoops
of course not like 24 and 24 gives white
a very nice compensation for the pawn
you will continue to develop very
rapidly but black has a very good
alternative here in giving the check and
there's some pretty much gives black
decent plane move like this here can
simply be answered by taking and now
grabbing on e4 this position is somewhat
similar to the one before but the
bishops here f8 and c1 arm and not on
the board anymore and this helps perhaps
like a lot because an issue was Bishop
g5 with the bishop still on the board
here black has no problems at all you
can just continue with normal
development even c6 can be considered
something like this here to block off
the bishop and here black is some yeah
almost you know simply pawn up with not
too much of compensation
on what the wide also can do is you can
place III here and you just take here
takes an unimportant move to to remember
is d5 well important to remember is it's
very relative because this line is super
round I never got it but well you need
to cover it in a video like that d5 the
Serbs a lot to to speed up development
whitest white takes here and then you
just drop the bishop back and black just
has a fine position you can easily
develop your pieces here and this pawn
configuration d5 and c3 it's not too
great for white as it gives like a nice
query on c5 probably for the knight
later and this Bishop is looking
somewhat silly at the moment black has
no problems at all P gives us check you
can simply exchange greens and have a
very really good endgame this pawn
weaknesses and square weaknesses are
just a nice target so this is so not too
dangerous note that this can also turn
out from d4 on the second move
you take Bishop c4 and Knight f6 okay um
well everything else here just to
suppose this into the Vienna just like
this as mentioned before um so let's
turn to to the Vienna remove water now
93 native 6 Bishop c4 of course there
are alternatives I all look at this
later in the video um and now I'm black
has really a multitude of options what I
don't recommend here my main move is
this what I don't recommend is to take
because this er has more than one
problem actually it is playable but one
issue here is the move from queen h5
Knight takes e4 would be no problem at
all because
five just to just to show this 94 d5 and
black wins back the PCM with a nice
position um let's say something like
this and black gum just enjoys this
slight advantage here in the center but
okay this is not the problem here
the problem with sevens is really direct
threat Iran f7 in now black doesn't have
anything else then this move here and
this can add either lead to some weird
complications after Bishop b3 or Queen
e5 with with a very equal position it's
not something I'd like to recommend um
you can play it but I thought what I'm
proposing is some is more interesting as
mentioned this is Bishop c5 an
alternative which is of course very very
decent is knight c6 um just to show it
briefly white usually replies d3 and
then you have the choice between 95
grabbing the bishop or Bishop before
with a very healthy development um this
actually was my main alternative I
wasn't sure what to show this this side
AB or Bishop c5 at the end I decided for
Bishop c5 because it is some not so well
known but also continued some some nice
some some nice points I'll show this
later d3 or later I show this now d3
here and now it's a very important
turning point
um the normal-looking move here would be
96 and it's it's playable
no no doubt about that but what I don't
like about this is that white can go f4
here and then d6 9 f3 and we transpose
into
yeah the Kings gambit declined this
position usually would arise in a
different move order so this stick that
show this quickly this can also arise in
this move order by the Kings gambit but
of course in the Kings gambit move honor
black has a multitude of other
possibilities
d5 as I showed but also the accepted
tone of other lines and to be honest all
these lines are I think more promising
and interesting than the decline
variation so what wide is often doing in
the Vienna move order this move order is
to try to to sort of trick black into
the Kings gambit declined um and of
course we don't apply shear and play
something else
my proposal here is the move rc6 this is
some somewhat rare a move but it's very
interesting the idea is some mostly to
prepared e75 to attack the bishop on c4
immediately and to get counter play in
the center should why try a form I think
the best move here for white maybe are
the most solid move here is some it's 9
f3 but of course f 4s is critical here
let's start with F form here you have
from a very nice and interesting choice
you can now go for a very solid setup or
form a multitude of very sharp options
on the solid move which can be played
and basically without ya knowing any
concrete lines is d6 here this has been
played by by some strong players already
the idea is neither 3 B 5 B should be 3
and then Knight B to this
this kind of setup this is in a way
similar to the Tilly's declined Queen's
Gambit Kings commit and the ska-tastics
commit that I showed before but in the
Kings gambit declined Black has the
knight on c6 and didn't have those Queen
side pawn moves in so there is a
difference and the difference is that
these pawns here nicely cover the
central squares why doesn't have control
over the d5 square and also with this b5
move it is pretty much secured that this
Bishop stays on c5 in the King's gambit
declined with the knight on c6 white
often has the chance to play 9 a4 and
exchange the bishop and this Bishop of
course is black so yeah most important
piece because it prevents right from
castling kingside this is very solid for
black and can be easily played if you
don't feel comfortable in the sharp
lines that I'm showing next star if you
just want to want to have from the a
Norman maneuvering game with all pieces
on the board this is of course a very
fighting position and can be played
easily so but now to the to the to the
sharp stuff what black can do also after
have fun which is very interesting are
two moves one really sharp and the other
said they are well both are sharp
let's let's start with e takes f4 this
is some the first option why then
recaptures on f4 usually um this is
mostly my own analysis so there's not so
much in game zone available so if you
intend to play this it's a good idea to
to set this up yourself on a board and
maybe check this with the computer and
those are some go through some lines to
get an idea what what this is about
what can also go if I've and as
mentioned the response to this
should be screw something up here there
should be d5 just it's it's very similar
in all these lines on e5 d5 to attack
the bishop and here white doesn't have
much choice he needs to to capture the
night um everything else is it's just
terrible let's say the bishop retreats
here then black can even go Knight g4
threatening Queen h4 and it's getting
really really ugly for white this Bishop
is also looking really stupid against
these pawns so he needs to take here and
now black black has a choice between 2
to sharp options I like Queen takes f4
f6 I most here you could also take here
and get a really messy position but I
think it's easily playable for black
you've got two bishops and the King arm
is not especially safe on white side
black can go for long castle in the long
run very complicated position but Queen
f6 I like even more the thing is it's
not really a piece sacrifice because
Knight H for a queen h4 is threatened
here so white cannot rescue the bishop
this is just a direct win it's either
made or a huge material loss it's just
just f2 here the problem so what usually
goes for should go for something like
this and then you have the cool move
King d8 now the bishop on c4 is hanging
still hanging and Ruby age is also
threatened winning the Queen so white
needs to go for something like takes
here takes on d5 Queen f3 rupee a check
night here and then the game continues
and it's a really really messy position
if you tend to play this it's a good
idea to maybe check this before some
somewhat invest some time and have a
closer look at this I cannot really go
forward 2020 move deep lines yeah I'm
just suggesting that this is an
interesting way to play but you need to
look at this for yourself a bit um wide
of course usually just would you capture
here this is a normal move and then
black castles here black will get good
play with the help of d5 next move and
this basically happens against
everything that white might play here um
for instance in five d5 is very nice for
black on an alternative could be a move
like d4 after which you pin here b5
we've also d5 bishop moves and 94 so on
this position I actually would prefer
black by far already
I think this Candice's c6 setup is a
nice weapon against this some white
intended plan to play a late f4 so why
does trying form sort of improved Kings
gambit and you should really allow this
another interesting possibility here
instead of taking is the direct move d5
and this can can get completely crazy
um why takes on d5 look sir looks
logical in my book he could also take on
e5 after which captured the bishop and
get the position like this and here also
would usually prefer black already black
has two super strong bishops and can
quickly casts a long ninety seven long
Castle okay you lose the corn
temporarily after he takes you forward
who cares
with such great piece play it's
absolutely no problem blankets very nice
here
the main issue here is e takes d5 after
this Black has a cool option in 94 just
directly I'm attacking him on on f2 and
this is I analyzed this briefly with the
computer and it it gives this as
somewhere between yeah equal and
slightly better for black guy but it's
completely crazy stuff just one sample
line could be d6 the ideas on Queen d6
to play a 94 night f2 of course this is
red and it's executed Queen h5 attacking
on on f7 wait so castles 94 so c5 is
hanging and this might continue Knight
takes D takes Queen b6 threatening
Bishop Queen before winning the bishop
and also G 1 so this is possess
necessary Queen before check 92 Bishop
e3 and this is really a crazy position
so what it comes down to this is just
one or two lines so that want to show to
give you an impression about the
sharpness of the position so this setup
was c6 and then going for a quick d5
after f4 is really an interesting way to
steer things up as black of course white
has some less aggressive alternatives
you can go Knight f3 after which you
just play d6 and cover the five pawn
black usually develops in a fashion like
the following
let's show show this briefly castles
Bishop to b6 it's a good idea to always
have the c7 square ready in case by
place Knight a four and now white
we'll continue developing here let's say
rupee one or something
castles H 397 bishop somewhere and then
one decent plan that black can go for us
move the rook and Knight to FA to g6 you
could also retreat to c7 play b5 so it's
a very flexible position and black has
no problems and developing all these
pieces to good squares um similar
picture um arises after move like Bishop
g5 here that can take this tempo and
then continue as mentioned 9 - f 8 let's
say deform and a g6 winning a tempo here
and then castles and black has a nice
position
- good Knights here - nicely control
those squares here and the center and on
the 4th rank the bishop is sir is also
actively placed you can go rook e8 to
play against you for this should be
around equal so I think this is a nice
way to to play with so here Bishop c5
and c6 so what what alternatives are
there here why term has some other moves
in the Vienna and this is mostly the
move f4 this is a very very old line it
dates back to the 19th century but it's
still played pretty frequently on an
amateur level it's so actually hard to
understand why because black has very
easy game if he knows just one or two
lines I think the main point why this is
played
still so often is some because sometimes
and less theoretically yeah expert
player might take on a form
and then e 5 is very nice for white
because blacks night doesn't have any
square so we needs to retreat them so
taking us is just bad what you need to
do is the just the logical move d5
always strike in the center against
those fo um attempts um and now white
takes on e5 in I don't know 99% of the
time while preparing this I actually saw
that there are a couple of games with a
takes d5 I wasn't really aware that this
is possible um a black here has two good
options just to take which I recommend
or you can also take here which leads to
a similar position to the Kings gambit
which I showed earlier
um but you can just take here
what's somewhat crazy idea is to take
now on e5 um something like this of
course it's no problem
you have no issue here with the Queen
developed early when the knight on b1 is
not existent anymore because it has been
exchanged against the g8 night then you
have no problem with the Queen yet as it
cannot be attacked like um I think
already at least equal here I would
prefer black because f4 is just a silly
move in such a position um okay F takes
d5 is the idea
just grabbing this pawn and the fun
thing is here white needs to play King
he too and this looks at completely a
crazy at first sight but it has has some
trick behind it and okay this this has
actually been played by nakamura
and now in a tournament game against
them Alexander only shook is also close
to 2700 player so so naka obviously and
when you said this is playable and it's
playable
I don't object to this it's just looking
a bit crazy the only thing here which
you need to remember is that tweeny
forum is not such a good idea it looks
nice
but the problem is why place king f2 if
you want to get your pawn back white
goes Knight f3 and gains lots of Tempe
on the Queen and why it is really quick
with development here he's got possibly
a Bishop b5 check coming up if you
retreat the Queen from the 5th rank and
rook e1 and d4 and white White has some
some nice active chances here so Queen
e4 is not so great but you can just
develop it's a really paramount in open
position develop your pieces quickly and
don't care so much about the pawn
temporarily we can see this here black
has so much pressure here on e5 and he
will cancel long that white um wants to
get the Queen's off with Queen e1
between h5 and now in this Nakamura game
with he played King t1 so white has made
some strange swapping of a queen and
king early but I think what what
ownership plane is just sufficiently
took on e5 so nice pin here on the on
the H 51 you want diagonal and it
continued like this rook e8 and black
gets his piece back with the roughly
equal position I'm okay this line is so
rare I doubt that you will ever get it
but it's nice to to have seen it once
that you don't go for this Queen you
fall this is a little trap Queen you for
this is quite quite nice for white so
just don't do that just continue with
quick development okay but the main move
by farm after d5 is of course taking on
e5 after which captures only four with a
knight and here white has to move really
then I played most often oneness and
this is also one of those cases we need
to know one line exactly d3 what you
need to know here is you shouldn't be
tempted by the check on h4 this is a
little fact that white has said this
check is some it's not good for black
because g3 Knight takes Knight f3 is
some as a problem
black needs to go Queen to h5 to keep
the spin on the Rooker life and then
white can catch on g5 and this is
somewhat crazy of course that could take
on h1 after which white would take on c7
and a 8 don't want to get into detail
but this is a very good variation for
white so don't fall into this trap you
can just take on c3 takes here and then
you need to remember the key move here
d4 this is very important if black would
allow Y to play D 3d form then white
might have some chances to to play for
our foreign advantage you need to play D
for yourself and I so sort of isolate
this pawn here this pawn doesn't have a
cover now by some other pawn and it will
be difficult for y to really to hold the
center let's say Knight f3 y dot already
offers a pawn here after taking on so
you hurry to play d4 black shouldn't
shouldn't shouldn't take it just develop
and now usually there should be two here
Bishop c5 castles and now you can
finally take this pawn and just continue
with your development like a support up
here and why it has some yeah wake
compensation but I think all in all
black is just just try neom um an
alternative for white would be to in
this position to take on default after
which you
in this check this is also a nice move
to throw in Bishop d2 taking and take on
d4 and black is is just great md5 is
just a weak pawn and white needs to be
careful not to have this whole position
completely shredded it's full of holes
already so mostly it continues with c3
here takes and now I'm I think black has
more than one good move but one that I
like is Queen d5 attacking a5 let's say
this and Bishop f5 black is just fine
here he's got the perfect pawn
configuration no pawn moved is of course
the ideal way to set up your points
because it has no weaknesses while white
has done a ton of pawn moves and the
position is full of holes
so next should have no problems here at
all it's just a question if it's what is
this slide advantage clear advantage is
it equal well I would say black is
somewhat more comfortable of at least um
so this is d3 but white can also go
Knight f3 here after this I would
recommend Bishop c5 directly hitting the
f2 square after which some white usually
plays default somewhat weird alternative
is Queen e2 after which you can just
give this check King you want White's
idea is to win some time now because
those advanced pieces of course need to
lose again so black just takes and then
retreats his piece here BC Bishop c5
let's say t4 returns Queen add alright
add a slot a slight problem here with my
recording software I hope it just
continues now I'm ok we were here white
playing Bishop to d3
and now just c5 and black has a nice
position because when whites King is not
especially great on d1 and his the less
some porn weaknesses white has no real
attacking chances here so no no problem
really white could also take here after
which you okay and need to retreat your
Bishop and just continue here with with
short castle and get on with development
white will always have issues with this
King he doesn't have any decent Square
or needs to lose lots of time to repair
the skin position so while Queen e2 is
not really threatening d4 is much more
common after which Bishop before just
pins the knight Bishop d2 so I guess the
only move and now just c5 I check the
center immediately black is already I
think at least equal here possible lines
could be um let's say a three you can
just take here and continue development
you have lots of nice pieces no problems
at all with getting your pieces out and
of course if is just a fantastic night
which really annoys white I guess on a
direct attempt by wide to get rid of the
knight can be played of course here you
can just recapture here white needs to
take on B form you cannot play something
like this B can just also you can just
capture capture the light because of the
pin okay takes here takes and now the
knight doesn't have any decent square
needs to return already this opening
cannot be considered as a success of
course say castles
Bishop c4 96 c3 takes takes and now just
to show a sample continuation Queen c7
threatening discoveries with the night
it should be three and then black even
can can sack a piece here
just to show this black here's three
pieces three pawns for the piece and
just a great position White has an
uncounseled King because it has moved
already you cannot cancel any more than
I just still on g1 so black ethically
advantage of course this is young moves
eighteen is just a sample line to show
that there's not much to p.m. I'm really
the Vienna with F for three or four is
just completely harmless and you should
welcome it if it is played against you
you just need to to note d5 and roughly
the lines I just showed you don't really
need to know and more I myself don't
don't know more and always get a nice
position um so what else is down here on
the third move of course whiter has some
some other tries he can of course just
play this which transposes into the four
nights this will be done in a later
video but another possibility here is g3
this Sun is some quite a decent line
actually it's not played so often but
it's a lot a bad choice if the white
player wants to avoid zone long
theoretical lines the idea is just to
develop with Bishop g2 Knight to e2 odd
f3 castles d3 and then maybe prepare a
for later
um black has two principled responses um
he can go for for a development sort of
approach like this
and set up the pieces in an ammonia zwei
just to show the general set up this can
always be played and should give black
decent chances to equalize the game the
other move which would be my main
recommendation here is to go d5 open up
the center yourself and this leads to
something like this captures 96 and now
White has a small choice here you can go
Knight f3 on I - E - 922 would still
leave the option of f4 open but can be
answered very nicely with Bishop e6 to
d4 this is something yeah you should
remember here in this position because
it simply leads to I think already an
advantage to black well I think I would
at least clearly prefer black here maybe
it's maybe equal but well what what more
can you hope for if you've got a nice
development great twin 95 and whites
Kings position looks somewhat shaky in
the long run um Knight f3 is much more
common also because this position often
arises from a different order I just
want to show this quickly it can rise
here from the four Knights with G 3
after which oops takes takes takes takes
leads to the same position and this is
actually the more common move order
nowadays um ok let's go back to to this
move order because after variation
stored
they're here black also has a multitude
of options you can develop this Bishop
to to any square and it should be okay
in any case but my recommendation would
be Bishop e7 here castles castles rook
e1 and then Bishop f6
the idea is to get some pressure on the
d4 point and prevent white from
advancing deform opening up the center
this is just one approach you can also
put the bishop on d6 on c5 as mentioned
but I like this one
to prevent deform rugby one often play
it here to get some pressure on b7 black
oops this was one button and black
should just cover this route b8 and then
maybe d3 Bishop e6 c4 Queen d7 just a
sample sample line black and black has
easily completed his development and
maybe you can think of playing a knight
to d4 at the later stage of first of
course maybe exchanging the e6 against
the g2 bishop this exchange would be a
would be nice for black in general he
has no no bad pieces at all and it's
nicely developed so I think there should
be it should be around around equal yeah
I think that's it from the vienna and
and bishops opening um this was actually
much longer videos than I expected but
well I guess I also gave some some
interesting information here I think
mostly these lines can be handled
without any deeper theoretical knowledge
of concrete lines um the only line which
I would recommend to further study if
you intend to play it is is this year
with c6 and Ford if you now want to go
for one of the sharp lines with d5 or
taking here you should really maybe set
up a board with an engine and
sort of go through the lines a bit I
invested I don't know about half an hour
and come on some really nice but what
truly complicated line said I don't want
to show here the video is already more
than forty minutes long so this would
have yeah made the video even longer
okay um this was the Vienna and bishops
opening the next video um to introduce
briefly will deal with other offbeat
trials on the second move which is if I
now think about it mostly deform and
some some gambit lines um and I'm not
sure what I'm doing when I'm doing this
maybe I don't have time tomorrow but I
will I would do this shortly it won't be
a week or so until the next video and
after this is done I get to the more
mainstream openings with Knight f3 and
ninety-six like the scotch or the
Italian game yeah well thanks for
watching and make sure to leave
questions questions or comments on
YouTube see ya